Oh, I see.
That's interesting.
Okay, so it's a voice chat.
And we have Craig joining us.
Yeah.
That's wonderful.
How are you?
How has your week been?
You
know, I actually had a really good week
until this morning.
I had someone, someone smashed the back of
my window on my car, like it's totally
smashed in.
It's, yeah, yeah, I'll send, see if I,
yeah, we know who it is.
And so I had to make a police report and
all that kind of fun stuff.
But yeah, it's unfortunate because I
actually had a really good week.
We went to the movies on Wednesday and I
saw Spider-Man.
The first time I saw a movie in a very
long time.
It was really, really good.
I would strongly, have you seen Superman,
the new one?
Or sorry, Spider-Man.
My goodness.
Spider-Man.
Oh, you did see it?
Oh, that's great.
Okay.
I really liked it because it wasn't about
a superhero fighting another superhero
that the world is going to end.
It actually had like a plot and a story
and struggles of people.
So it was a really nice change to like the
DC comics or Marvel.
Normal, typical movies around,
you know, all these superheroes get
together to, you know, save the world.
It was a lot different.
Very enjoyable.
Very good movie.
So yeah, other than that, pretty.
Yeah, no, other than that, it was a good
week and a busy week and a very productive
week.
So that's also a good thing.
Of course, better being busy than bored,
as they said, or they say.
I feel that you have made quite a bit of
progress over the last, when you took the
week off, and you've, you know,
you've put in a lot of effort with talking
on the chat forums.
And I think if I'm, if I understand what
we're going to do this afternoon,
it's more around you know, you will walk
us through together the JavaScript,
it's to lead the conversation.
Again, it's about leading a conversation,
leading the, almost calling it
facilitating a meeting.
We don't have to call it teaching about
JavaScript.
But I think even if we spent 20 minutes or
30 minutes going through the first five or
six sections where you drive, you can read
right off the agenda, or you can,
you know, you can go off script,
as it's called, and just start talking as
you as you would at work or with a
colleague about JavaScript and what it is,
and just try to inform me as a colleague,
maybe pretend that I'm, pretend that I'm,
you know, in business development or
something, I have very little technical
background, or maybe I do have technical
background, I just don't know much about
JavaScript.
That, I think will give us a good
impression of your comfort level talking
technically.
And then yes, the interview questions,
the going back to that format,
I think that we start small, and in that
format, we'll start off with the two
important questions about, tell us about
yourself, a little bit about yourself and
your background, and why are you applying
for the role?
And then we'll take very small or medium
sized steps on some of the expected
behavioral and technical questions.
And we can pick, what we could do is pick
a job description that you would typically
consider applying for, maybe in Spain,
or Italy, or, you know, wherever it is.
And then we work towards that job
description, and that job role.
Yep.
Okay.
Yes.
However, I'll say, I'll say that with the
technology that you're using, so the
technical questions that you practice on,
I can listen to your responses.
But I, in addition, create or select,
you know, two or three major work
experiences on the behavioral side,
right?
So your most challenging project,
your most technically complicated project,
a project that you're most proud of or
successful, and all, and also the project
that failed.
It's becoming much more popular now,
I've been reading in the changes to the
industry trend, especially around tech.
It, that question actually comes up about
60% of the time now in interviews.
Tell me about an initiative, a project,
a major activity that you were leading or
were part of that failed?
And why did it fail?
So not always, not always the happy path
question.
So yeah, I like your approach.
That's great that you found a website,
you can practice the technical questions
around front end technology.
And then you and I, I can listen to your
answers as well.
And then equally, we can focus more on the
behavioral and budget-based or
experience-based questions that will also
come that may not have as much technical
in-depth responses.
Yeah, good.
Oh, I like these.
I like these emojis.
It's awesome here.
Guys freaking me out.
Did you want me to share screen and then
go through the agenda or where you will
drive the sections?
Or did you want to share?
Oh, no, you haven't.
Live?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Yeah, I see.
I see.
Well, okay.
No, it's in Russian.
I don't know what it is.
That's okay.
Good.
Yeah.
Do you want me to ask questions right
away?
Or do you want me to wait until you're
sort of done the topic?
Okay.
I like the dark.
I like the dark mode, by the way.
I wish I could do dark mode.
Yeah, I've used both.
Yes.
But maybe it would be beneficial if you
actually talked about what is the purpose
of building a local project?
So, like, what is a project in your in
your view?
Why are we building a project within,
like, a JavaScript?
Yeah.
But is a project a place that you build an
application in?
Like, why are we using the word project?
Like, is it just a way for me to
categorize?
Like, is it a way for me to
compartmentalize or separate the different
applications that I'm going to be
building?
Compartmentalize.
Yeah.
So, or to keep it separate.
To compartmentalize.
So, to keep separate.
It means, like, if we're going to build,
if we're going to practice programming,
is one project practice programming and
then maybe another project might be
building Tetris or a game?
Like, is that kind of what the meaning is?
You kind of, I can separate the major
activities as to what I'm doing from a
programming perspective?
You know what I mean?
Like,
so, so maybe, maybe let me say it in a
different way.
Why would I create a new project?
What's the purpose of me creating a
project?
Is it simply to start?
Or is it simply for me to practice?
Or is it, let's say I wanted to,
let's say I wanted to build a very simple
website and then on another thing I wanted
to build Tetris.
So, would I have two different projects?
One for building a website and one for
building Tetris?
Is that the purpose of project to,
you know, have different major activities
in different areas?
Yeah.
Sure.
Yes.
Okay.
Would I, okay, would I, would it,
would I build two websites or two,
yeah, two different kinds of websites
within the same project?
Or would I have two different projects?
Would I create a new project for one
website for about business and one website
about, you know, information about
something?
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you for explaining.
Now I understand.
Okay.
And I can watch you, I can watch you do
some of the magic as well.
Totally.
I got visual representation, sort of set
up of JavaScript and what you're doing
and, you know, why we're doing it in that
way.
And so it works, it works just as well as
that if I was doing it.
Simple.
Presenting image, random images make me
happy each morning.
Random images.
Yeah.
The important thing is to describe what
the index.html does.
So it's where you can set the title,
you can set the font size, you can do
readings and all sorts of things in terms
of format of the text.
I guess that's really what I mean here.
Yeah.
And as I understand it in the world of
programming, correct me if I'm wrong,
but a variable is typically a way to
either use local or global memory
allocation.
Sure.
I mean, but that by definition,
that's kind of the definition,
right?
You would use a local variable,
let's say in a procedure, but versus like
how you described it, you can have a
global variable, which you can call or use
later on, wherever you want to call it
within the program, whether it's a string,
whether it's a string or some other
varchar or some other element.
That's okay.
Let's continue.
Okay.
Sure.
Slippers.
Yeah.
$8.
Okay.
Good.
Great.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, no, of course, of course.
Yes.
Before.
Yeah.
Okay.
Good.
So you explained that well.
You explained that very well.
So that's, yeah, that's, it's the purpose
of being able to explain something and
have direct contact.
So that's, that's good.
Explaining the difference and you provided
an example from an existing document that
you have and the structure that's
associated to it.
So very good.
Sure.
Yeah.
So it would be.
So do not forget that right now,
your agenda running on a Chrome website
right now is utilizing 872 megabytes of
memory.
So if you hover over, if you actually
hover over the tab, the tab for this
specific agenda document is 872 megabytes
of physical memory on the computing
device.
Yeah.
No.
So you've described the variable types,
which is grid.
There's you're showing true examples,
true real world examples, especially of
our agenda working.
So it's, it's good.
We've gone through an array and then the
examples.
Now you're going to go through some,
you know, there's Booleans like true or
false, zero or one.
Well, let's say if you're comparing,
let's say that if you're comparing sales
from a table between John and Andrew and
on one, one column, there's something like
you set up the values before you
categorize them as to like category or
products being shoes and slippers.
Instead, you could do something like sales
from January, February, March,
April, and then you do that for yourself.
And then you can use these comparison
calculations to calculate which is larger,
for example.
Sure.
So
what you're doing here is you're actually
what's called in my, as I understand it,
you're hard coding the value rather than
pulling the information from the database
that would be presented in this structure.
Correct?
Boolean.
Sure.
Well, you're almost referring to filtering
out of a set of lists or conditions,
right?
So a business case could be that you
present a dropdown in a box and,
you know, you have the text on a web page
of these three elements, the ID,
the client name, and are they active or
not?
And you can select from, let's say,
a radio button or a dropdown list,
you know, you can present it in whatever
format you want, and you can do something
like filtering.
You could filter on active versus
inactive.
Perhaps you may want a list of all of your
inactive clients for whatever reason.
So this is what you can do with these
kinds of elements, if I'm describing that
correctly.
Good.
Mm-hmm.
Yes.
Yeah.
And the display.
So it'll return the value and display it
how you would like.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Right.
So isn't it incre—isn't it—oh,
sorry, keep going.
Yeah.
I was just going to say, so it's
incredible the passage of time,
you know, when you're teaching something
from the beginning.
And it's, like, you've led the
conversation for probably 40 or 45
minutes.
And, you know, we've gone through—yeah,
it's incredible.
But look, look how much you've talked and
led and driven the conversation.
And you have not struggled, and you've
explained it very, very well.
In simple terms, in business terms,
and you've interacted with me a little
bit.
Not a lot, but at various stages,
there's been, you know, some good
interaction.
So, you know, based on my feedback on how
this is going, I mean, you've structured
this and explained it quite well,
the beginnings of what we're doing and
provided a real-world example.
So it's—I'll just say, you know,
well done in terms of describing various
things to consider when you're setting up
your environment and some of the things
we're looking to do.
And here's a data set, some elements,
and what we can do with these elements.
So it's—how have you—are you surprised 47
minutes passed by like that?
Yeah.
So it's good.
It's good.
I mean, and you can see the time it's
required to learn something, right?
Imagine teaching JavaScript from someone
who knows nothing about tech, right?
Setting up the environment, explaining
F12.
Like, we jumped—how many steps did we jump
ahead, you know, setting up the overview,
right?
Like, it's quite amazing.
It's quite amazing.
So, you know, I think you've technically
described things at the proper level as
well.
So I think, you know, I think for next
session, we can probably either continue
this a tiny bit, but I think we could
transition then into a little bit of a
half lesson and then a half dry run on
some interview questions.
But I don't know what you're thinking
about next after this, because I think
you're in a good spot right now.
You were describing it quite well
technically and showing real examples of
setting it up.
What do you think?
Yeah.
Sure.
I'm thinking about questions like,
tell me the tools that you're most
familiar with and, you know, what would
you describe them to be and what is your
level of expertise, right?
So you would say, you know, CRM,
ERP and, you know, the things that you
maybe do.
So a product list.
We start, like you said, baby steps.
The major areas in technology that you're
quite technically familiar with at the
expert level, at the advanced level,
whatever it might be.
Yeah, I would love it if you shared some
questions and likewise, I would do the
same.
And if you have time to prepare a little
bit, you don't have to answer them
perfectly.
It's more about trying and see how we do.
You know, and like you said, we'll keep
the simple approach first and go from
there.
OK.
Good.
Well, well done.
Thank you for leading.
As you've seen, it goes quick.
And not only that, you led very well.
I'll be interested to see the script as
well and summarize it actually at the next
lesson, too.
That would be interesting, too,
to analyze a bit.
So, yeah.
Thank you very much for, as we call it in
English, driving.
You did well.
Good.
Sure.
Yeah, and if you could share the script,
if you get an output of the text,
that would be great to throw in here at
some point whenever you have time.
We can do it at the next lesson or before.
But, yeah, have a wonderful weekend ahead
and, you know, enjoy whatever you're going
to do.
And we will speak on Tuesday.
Thank you, sir.
Thanks, Andrew.
Bye-bye.